when i blow your [ __ ] head off or
when i know about that yes jay kirby
your punch man knocked him out one punch
is this man dead he can't be dead
i've just killed someone
[Music]
what kind of kid were you when you were
growing up
um
active
energetic confident
um outspoken i wasn't shy
i kind of i don't know i felt like a bit
of a protector around my friends that i
felt were vulnerable you know
and stuff like that bit of a defender if
you could say that you know
what would you say
was a turning point in your life
well it has to be in 2003 and when i was
19
and um
my best friend at the time
called me
he told me
that
him and his girlfriend he was with at
the time i've been going for a bit of a
rough patch not talking to each other
maybe for like a week or two you know on
and off sort of thing but during that
period of time when they were going
through their rough patch
she um his girlfriend got raped by
somebody
when my
boy first told me
what happened i said to him
why didn't your girl go to the police
and he said she's scared to go to the
police
and she just wanted him to do something
to just stop this man from
you know
troubling her again
the plan was he was gonna pull up at the
bus stop what he did
and meet her moves in a phone box
waiting for him
with two baseball bats
when he did arrive
came out the phone box we approached him
as he was talking to the girl
he saw us coming
um he grabbed a girl and held her why
are you gonna grab her like that and
hold her like a shield you've done
something guilty my reaction was to hit
him with the bat to get him off of the
girl my boy done the same thing hit him
a few times he let go of the girl
then obviously he was trying to disarm
me and take my battle for me
i'm
tasking him with the man getting back
and forth he's trying to get the battle
for me i'm hitting him some more it was
more just a human reaction thing in it
you
rapist monster man is not taking this
baseball bat off of me
so if i have to keep swinging it and
hitting you so you can't take it off of
me
and maybe turn it back on me then that's
what's going to happen and i just kept
swinging it until he stopped trying to
grab it he dropped on the floor on one
knee and then i just ran across the road
shouted to my boy let's go we ran off
and
that was it basically
from where i lived at the time
we could see the
police put up the tent around his body
and all the road taped off
and stuff and um they were just there
for hours and that's why i started to
think this has probably gone way too far
because why is there a tent around him
is this man dead he can't be dead i only
hit him a few times at the baseball bat
in the head and around the shoulder neck
and wherever else
was about i don't know five or six days
later crime stoppers put posters up
around
the streets where it happened
saying that the man had died is there
any information on this man
to this day you know it's a strange
feeling
sometimes you don't really
know what that feeling is but it's there
it's hard to explain
um
no no
you feel bad about yourself i know you
question yourself
like i'm a bad person i'm a good person
you know am i wrong am i right
i know i'm a religious person as well so
i think it's in the hands of god in it
i was out with my
friends on a night out
um it was one of my friends 18th
birthdays
and
we were just out all day drinking as the
clubs closed on that night
i got some calls from my friends who i
got separated with who were in another
bar causing trouble
and they would ring me up and say oh
jacob is kicking off you need to come
come back us up
so me being the you know what 18 19 year
old i was back then
i only cared about my friends
and so i went running down to the scene
and
i sadly
took it upon myself to
get involved and
through
i threw a punch at the guy that my mate
was arguing with and um
and he fell on the floor
my friends came around the next day
knocked on the door
i answered
out the window
and um their response was
yes jacob you know your punch man
knocked him out one punch
like trying to like
praise me um for what i did
and i guess at the time i felt a little
bit of a
little bit of pride getting that
acknowledgement
from my friends
and then a couple more weeks passed and
i ended up my mum had saved up some
money to actually take us on holiday
um
we went to tenerife
and then a couple of days later after
we'd come back from the holiday the
police
started raiding me and all my friends
house and this was a month after that
punch
and then that's when it started to
become a reality that
someone had actually
passed away because of my
actions
how did it make you feel
a mixture of every
unpleasant emotion combined
shock
self-pity
and i i guess at that time i also felt
unfortunate i felt like i was um
why why has this happened to me my mum
was um
the best way to describe it is
hysterical
she just kept crying about
the pain that
the other person's
mum
would be feeling
and
i find that really difficult to
even try and think about
the court hearing was hard you know for
me because
all i'm thinking is
i just want this jury to hear from the
girl
she was excluded from our trial she's
got a plea bargain for conspiracy to
assault
she's the reason why i heard this guy
why this all started obviously we're not
gonna hear from the guy we need to hear
from her
and they didn't get to hear from her so
it was difficult for me you know
sitting in there
as a young black man i thought oh my god
i'm already on the back foot
yeah i just had to just just sit there
and just take it all in and then
sometimes when your barrister isn't
saying what you want him to say and
fighting for you how you want him to
fight then you know you can't really
jump up in the court and
start saying no you didn't say that
right supposed to say this and say that
because obviously it compromises your
character you're gonna have old jewelry
looking at you like you're some savage
you're not trying to be a savage are you
just trying to be a normal person
the court hearing was um
it was packed
i didn't know who was in there it was
like random people from off the street
who had managed to get in there who just
being nosy there was
some of my family in there
people who i didn't know journalists
and then obviously
i was told
that
you know the family of the
of the
person who passed away was also
in the room
so i think what i did is i put my head
down
looked at the floor
for the entire
process because i played
guilty early so there was like no trial
or anything i didn't try and
um
what they could say boss case or
you know try and get away with it
and and yes and then all of a sudden i
was looking down at the floor and the
prison guard next to me pulled me
down
and uh
i didn't even know how long it got
i didn't even know that it was all over
and i was going to prisons
were you scared
yeah
i was scared and um
it just felt awful to be honest
what was your sentence
it was 12 years uh
but i did eight months i'm a man so the
judge ended up he sentenced me to 11
years and 127 days
it's only 19 at the time i'll get out
when i'm 30 something
i was sentenced to
i think it was 13 months
in the end was two and a half years
um an early guilty plea gets you a third
off your sentence
i hadn't had any
previous
criminal convictions
my probation officer kind of
wrote to the church in the pre-sentence
report just saying that she felt the
longer that i was probably in prison
the more unhelpful it may have been
tell me about your childhood my dad was
a builder my mum was a state-owned mum
like she had eight kids i was the baby
so i got spoiled
and i went to good schools i went to
grammar my family was all straight goers
i was the one who corrupted them all i
was waiting for a pile couple of my old
school friends one of them left a
starting pistol so the two coppers come
in
and i they started getting everywhere
and i went oh you can't do that
i said you've got a responsible adult
prop you know there you mean what are
you a lawyer i said no but i know my
rights
and he went okay walked out they come
back threw a razor on the floor cut
throat
and um he went where nick can you that
come out your pocket oh when we talking
about so they nicked me took me stone
knowing then he said they said if you
play guilty it'll be a timber fine if
you don't play gil and you go up the
steps he said you're going to get balls
for that so i've done guilty
when i've gone back to work of course
they've read it in the newspaper i lost
my job
and with criminal record it was very
hard to get another job so what opened
up to malfoy if you're gonna make me a
bad guy i'll show you how bad i can be
people said call me a gang so i didn't
like it one guy called me a gangster
stuff stuck a gun in his mouth and
educated him that i weren't a gangster
and i said that i'm a businessman and my
business is crime at one stage
i'm sitting in the pub uh all my pals
having a drink because they'll drunk and
tony agree come into me he said do you
know the fish and chip shot where your
mum and dad goes
i went yeah he said well they're in bits
he said like a couple of turkish guys
got their daughter on heroin and trying
to get her out on the game
and i went do what he said yeah and i
know this family there are working
people you know you know fish and chip
shop from dinner time working through
the night time you know covered in
grease and they're nice people he said
and they know about you they've heard
about you and they want to talk to you
and make it go away
i said okay so
i got him see him and he had this
biscuit him bless him and he don't know
the biscuits and he had rolls of notes
in it he said bobby he said you know
crying his wife's crying and i felt bad
you know and he said you know these
people terrible people you know tell me
what they'd
he said and we don't want the problem we
work people we said we you know
i said don't worry and make her go away
so he gave me the biscuit tim and it was
their savings and i take money off of
them i'm going to nick it off for people
who really got it so i said no i said
what you do
if we come in here we get fish and chips
free and if my mum and dad come up here
you give them their fish and chips for
it okay i said that's the price so i've
come out and frank was sitting in a
motor he was my driver old frank
he went what's going on i said tomorrow
i said at seven o'clock in the morning i
said bring the car around i'm not
messing about with these people they're
dangerous so i'm going to shoot them so
i got out the motor
got the sawn off one's under a car i
walked in and i shot him through the leg
and i went i'll blow your [ __ ] head
off i went out about that i said if you
ain't off the manner in 24 hours going
to blow your brains out what does it
feel like to shoot someone
well i won't shoot him in my head right
because they used to say how do they do
it so you don't feel bad about it they
say we've got a rat
so they dehumanize them they're not a
person anymore they're a rat so what i'm
shooting is vermin so i had no problem
with it but you've got to dehumanize
them so that they're just an object to
be targeted and you target them and you
do it to me everything was business it
didn't matter whether i liked you i
didn't like you if someone said to me
there's x amount of pounds when i'm shot
in the leg
i'm going to look at it and think right
if i treat him i'll get caught i'm going
to do this much jail if i'm clever and i
don't get caught
that's my money if i shoot it so it's
not as glamorous as people think it's
like anything where you're shooting them
cutting them once you've done one half a
dozen eight too many you become hardened
and that's why it's very hard to show
love and emotion that sort of thing
because you've got to bring the shutters
down because if you're done you'd go
insane or you put one in your own mouth
you know
you remember the first mission you were
sent on yeah i can it was in iraq we're
in the maisan desert and the mesan
desert is a vast
vast
place and it's desolate we were getting
scouted
by
a motorbike and every time we saw this
motorbike loads of mortars were coming
the artillery and the mortars were
getting pretty damn close and then i got
the green light to um
take the target out i shot
um missed my first shot second shot i
got him
and then i had to go up to the body to
to see if i'd um
if he he was
you know dead
and i remember walking up to the body um
the motorbike the the throttle was stuck
in the sand and the bike was revving and
an ak strapped to it
and
the guy was
on the floor and he he passed away
um he had shot him here
yeah
weird weird feeling weird feeling you
feel like you're in trouble
you feel
i've just killed someone
but people are thanking you going oh
yeah good shot tapping your shoulders
good shot good you know good mission
there craig well done
but you just killed someone a strange
feeling strange feeling
snipers working in pairs yes they do
yeah can you explain that for me you
have one and number two now number two
he's usually the best sniper
because he'll work out all your
calculations he'll work out all the wind
everything you need to know for your
scope and basically then he will tell
you to put it in and all you've got to
do is pull the trigger the number one is
probably the best shooter we gotta
understand then that snipering is not
all about shooting and killing
the first job of a sniper is to gather
lifetime information
of the battlefield
so i'd look for my scope i'd see
a bloke come out of his compound with
his
with a lady and
i would
make up the story say oh there's limpy
john with his wife and it keeps your
mind occupied and goes oh let's see what
bevel's doing and then you go over to
bevel oh let's see what bob's doing oh
yeah there's bob doing the same old
thing it's quite hard really because
when you do get to take the target out
you're killing bob
you know and you've made a name up for
him for the last four days
you know but that's the sort of thing
you need to mentally switch off
let's go through some of the other
missions you're on are there anything to
stand on your head
as dangerous one mission we were in
basra palace and we got go to this place
called the p-jock and
the p-drop basically just run by 15
people that's it
and it's next to a prison and it used to
get smashed every single night from
11 o'clock at night or five in the
morning it is the gates of hell
the gates of hell and they're trying to
release
all these insurgents all these other
hierarchy
taliban from this prison and it was our
job to not let him do that we were
on the roof
on this occasion
and they came from
north they came from the south they came
from the east they came from the west
they came from everywhere
and um
we got absolutely
i'm gonna say we got absolutely smashed
we thought we were gonna go over
so i phoned tanya
i get a bit upset you know sorry
um
i phoned her and she answered
and um
and i said to her i love you you know
then
because i know
she goes what's what noise
and i said that has nothing that's
nothing
i just want to hear a voice you know
just wanted to hear
her voice
and we went back on the roof and yeah we
ruined the fight
it was like a wall got shattered
and when that wall of ice got shattered
everything that i've experienced in my
tools
through bosnia kosovo
iraq afghan
i couldn't
i couldn't stop it
my wife noticed it first
she knows there's something wrong due to
my isolation
my
snappiness
just depression really and
suicidal thoughts
i'm not gonna lie i will cry later
because a lot of memories come up you
know a lot of thoughts
i don't i don't disguise it you know i'm
a big advocate for ptsd but i find i'm
ashamed to have ptsd and i i'm the first
one to admit it ruins your sex life
it ruins
ruins your friends because no one wants
to be around you because you're just
miserable
you don't want to go out because you get
so
angry so quick
the army noticed it and i got called
into the mo's office which is the
medical officer's office
from doing 20 odd years
took half an hour for me to get kicked
out
yeah i'll say it my wife
we went to america
um stayed there for a bit
and um
my wife went back to england to see her
mum
and i uh
yeah i nearly shot myself
i took all the rounds out the gun i was
practicing where to do it
where i would do it
and um
i put the bullet in cocked it
put it in my mouth
and betsy was sat on the back of the
sofa
she's um
little yorkshire terrier
she's in my life
i wouldn't be here now
i have a sat talking to you guys or
on this planet if it wasn't for my wife
and my dog
no [ __ ] way
i would have checked out
it's hard it's hard it's hard
you were sentenced to manslaughter do
you talk to us a little bit about what
happened that was a bad one you know
that's the only thing i've got on my
conscience that i have to live with that
is the oddest thing i have to live with
someone chokes on a gag on a bit of work
you know and and they choked on it on me
and they want to explain what that is
it's a bad place for me you know like
we've done a hundred times your time up
you get them yeah you go
the please come one time boom if i could
undo that one just let one
that would be the only thing in my life
i would undo
why do you think
the death of that victim at your hands
has caused you so much kind of mental
pain
because it should never have happened
and even to this day i have to live with
it i've done an innocent
and
you don't do that in my world you don't
do innocence
and uh not that one i feel terrible
about but when i go to church because
i'm catholic i believe in in that sort
of thing i always like a candle for that
person like i do my mum and dad and my
daughter who died you know i like
candles for him it's a respect for and i
said prayer for him you know
do you have any regrets about what you
do
no i don't you know because
i believe what i've done was right
from my heart
i've looked it in my head time and time
and time and time and time again over
and over and over again am i wrong am i
right and i feel like i don't know i
feel like yeah i'm kind of right
there's one less rapist on the earth
and that's gotta be a good thing
do you think
it's the right thing to take power in
your own hands in this sense or do you
think we should aim at the police to
address this
the police
officer got raped um and raped and
murdered a girl the other day
how can you go to the police
a police officer was convicted for
raping and killing a girl the other day
right
so where are we going with this the
police are doing the same things so how
can you go to the police
i can girls go to the police they're
going to go to their boyfriends they're
going to go to their friends they're
going to go to their brothers they're
going to go to their dads you're going
to go to somebody that's probably going
to do something about it straight away
and not be like um we're going to
investigate and give you a crime number
and get back to you and you're scared to
go to the shops now
you can't go at your house
scared
how much women out there have been raped
and violated and and and kids have been
violated by pedophiles and that
ask them how they feel
about people like that whether we should
take the law into our own hands
and um sometimes dish out our own
justice
if it's a monster
then you know
i'm not really haunted by that you know
would you would you do the same thing
for your friend for your mom for your
sister for your brother
you know
i mean she makes us question our own
selves and it's humans in it
would you do the same thing again
if i was put in that situation again
i have a defending i'm a defender
if i have to live my life in prison
being a defender then that's what i'm
gonna have to do and then if i have to
die in prison being a defender then i'm
gonna die in prison being a defender and
at least i can live in myself and myself
and say i defended something for the
right reason
did you feel a lot of guilt
at the time i did feel a lot of guilt
but i didn't know what to do with it
because
how could i ever
how could i ever know
what
what the impact was
and i kind of think i was scared of
knowing
what the truth was like how that crime
had actually
impacted on the people involved
and you know i was told by the parents
that
james was the
type of person where
he'd want me to
make something
of of my life and
amount to something positive
that helped me
try to believe in myself a little bit
more
um
because i knew i wouldn't be able to
achieve anything if i was just
stuck in the
guilt and shame of what i'd done
and that's when they asked me you know
what is it that you're gonna actually do
with your life jacob because it's
it's okay saying
i didn't even want to say the word sorry
i said you know i feel like it'll be an
insult to say the word sorry i want to
prove to you through my actions that
actually i'm sorry
and um
and then
you know that's when it says okay what
are you gonna do
so i said i'll give gcs he's another
shot at 21 years old and um
and smashed him
did his mom ever tell you that she
forgives you
um
yeah
but i didn't ever want to um
expect forgiveness
and i understand that forgiveness isn't
something that is black and white
forgiveness
means different things to different
people
what advice would you give to your
younger self
forget religion forget color
forget sex
boils down to in life two things are you
a good person or a bad person
that's all it boils down to do you ever
mess the old life
so i had to go through hell
right
to appreciate heaven
and that's what you have to see ugliness
to appreciate beauty
you have to
witness hatred and venom
to appreciate love and kindness
i actually thought he was going to walk
off
and i'll see him look at me and he he
had a fault
and now i know what the fault was
i've got to kill him and he just walked
up to me and he just went
bang bang straight